[Music]
in
1972 something very special was
happening lots of special things
happened in 1972 it was really really an
amazing period of time in fact but as
far as chess what happened in
1972 is Bobby fiser American grandm
Bobby fiser actually his name is Robert
James fiser we all called him Bobby
Bobby challenged the Soviet
Grandmaster who was also the world chess
champion Boris basy to a world
championship match and it lasted two
months that match lasted if you think
about a boxing match that boxing match
heck that could last 5 minutes
one minute 20 minutes but if you think
about a basketball game that lasts 60
Minutes or a football game that could
last 60 minutes but a world championship
match lasted two
months and in those days in
1972 basically everybody got their news
and information there was no computers
there was no internet there were no cell
phones we got our news from the TV and
from the newsp
and every day on on the newspaper they
would give a report of what happened in
game one game two game five game 10 game
14 and so on and I was in Rapture I love
to read what Bobby fiser was doing and
that's how I became interested in
chess
well in
1972 there was a man his name was Walter
kronite and Walter kronite read the
evening
news and in my household we would turn
on the TV and we would watch that news
report and Walter kronite was literally
like a father to the nation as he gave
the report and everybody watched the
evening news with Walter
kronite and there was a lot of things
going on the president of the United
States at the time was a guy by the name
of Richard Nixon and Richard Nixon was
being
impeached Watergate we were at war in
Vietnam there was a war going on hip hop
was just being coming out uh do you guys
know Bruce Lee in martial arts yeah
Bruce Lee was was coming in into fashion
so a lot of things would happen and
Walter kronite I remember watching him
he would come on the evening news and he
would say good evening America this is
Walter kite CBS news today and then he
would go on and read what the news was
and that's what he did this one show I
was watching he'd say today's news we
have a b c d all of these things and
then he would say but now the really
important news is let's figure out what
happened between Bobby Fischer and Boris
basy
he stopped the Evening News to focus on
the world championship chess match wow
that was so cool oh I was so excited
chess was front page news for two months
it was on the TV and PBS how many of you
know PBS public broadcasting station PBS
would have one hour shows every day
Shelby Lyman was the host of the show
and I would watch those shows as well
well okay so I got really really excited
about
Chess and I remember this when I was a
kid I was 12 let me repeat myself I was
a good kid my mom and dad they loved me
why because when it was time for me to
go to bed no problem I went to bed I
love my sleep if they said 7:00 bedtime
I was right out there they said 7:30
bedtime no complaints I went right to to
bed my parents loved me cuz I loved my
sleep so we had no
problem well one day there was a party I
think a friend got married so we went to
a wedding and then there was a wedding
reception and it just kept going on and
on and instead of seven it was 8 instead
of 8 it was 9 instead of 9 it was 10:
and I really really wanted to go to bed
we left the party at 11 at night way
past my bedtime I was super super tired
so finally we made it home and it was
really late at night and like most
American parents they we got into the
house they turned on the lights they
turned on the
TV and I was going to my bedroom and I
remember it very very clearly like it
was
yesterday the TV was set to the Johnny
Carson show well he was a late night
host and he would interview important
celebrities and Johnny Carson came on
and he said and tonight we have a very
special guest the world chess champion
Bobby fiser so I was on my way to the
bedroom and when I heard that turned
around I went back to watch the TV
because I wanted to see Bobby fiser I
discovered at the Seattle Public Library
that Bobby fiser had written a chess
book and that chess book was called
Bobby Fisher teaches
chess how many of you have seen that
book or know about it even I think I
think I'm not sure I think there's a
copy here at the St Louis chess club
Library okay Bobby Fisher teaches chess
so I went to the public library got my
card got my membership and I checked the
book out so I could read the
book and it was amazing Bobby Fisher's
book Bobby fiser teaches
chess talks about one
tactic 200 Pages the back rank chessmate
I said my God this guy's a world
champion but he's a one trick pony all
he knows is the back ranked Checkmate
but I
figured if Bobby fiser was the world
champion and he wanted me to know what
the back rank Checkmate was I better
learn it so today we're going to teach
you the back ran checkm now notice that
white has obviously had castled and
White's last move was this move black
had obviously castled but let's try to
understand what's going on in the
situation white has one two three four
five pawns black has one two three four
pawns so black reasons holy cow I'm a
Pawn behind I got to win that pawn back
yes Charlie Rook takes
C2 that's exactly right black reasons
that this Pawn if he could capture this
Pawn he would
restore the material imbalance and now
it' be 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 we'd be in a
completely symmetrical position but
black overlooks one thing yes young
man Rook on E1 can go to and that's
precisely right The Rook on E1 goes to
E8 it's Checkmate to the black king
because Black's beautiful Pawn Shield
right that protects his
King Black's Black's Pawn Shield
protects his King from a frontal attack
if this Rook were here or here or here
or here Black's King has no problems but
this attack comes along the rank in this
case the back rank the eighth rank or
from Black's point of view the first
rank is the back rank in this case
Black's King is trapped by his own Pawn
Shields these loyal loyal centuries
these bodyguards are preventing the
king's escape the king King cannot move
towards the Rook because the Rook
attacks that square so black is in
check and mate
that's so that is a primary example
that's a simple simple example of a
checkback
okay okay so it's a very balanced
position right 1 2 3 1 2 3 1 2 3 1 2 3
so 6 versus 6 in terms of Pawns and both
sides have a pair of
Rooks it's white to move now we notice
the first thing we notice in the
position is White's Rook is on an open
rank White's Rook is on an open rank so
when our Rooks are on an open rank the
ideal is to come to the seventh rank so
we can eat all all of these Pawns in the
Soviet Union the seventh rank was called
the refreshment stall that's where the
Rooks would go to get a refreshment they
go to the seventh Rank and they eat a
pawn so white begins with the move Rook
to E7 attacking Black's Pawn black
really desperately wants to
return return the compliment and get his
Rook to the seventh ring
but black sees a problem black sees that
after this Pawn is captured black cannot
capture this Pawn because it's protected
so as tempted as black is to go to the
second rank he black first starts with
the move Rook C8 C7 a defensive move yes
young man well when that happen another
reason um D would want to move there
because you're getting close you know
what I'm about to introduce is black
first plays this defensive move Rook C8
to guard his Pawn that White's last move
threatened now white is very clever
Charlie Rook E1 correct Rook
A1 to E1 now what this is called is a
battery so what a battery means is we
double the power we double the power
behind I
know okay
like if you like the r captures the that
is on E7 it's guarding it's still
guarding that's right it's on the same
like it's in the same column exactly so
white doubles Rooks on on the open files
yeah
now black makes
it decisive error almost a suicide kind
of move what black should probably do
is move a pawn in front of his King to
give his King uh do you know the word
lft l oh yeah it's a German word that's
correct lft is a German word and it
means air so the German national
airliner is called Luft Hansa as an
airplane okay so we say in chess that
black could give his King lft by moving
a pawn in front of his King to escape
the back rank Checkmate yes young man
you meant the airlin in Germany Lans yes
oh yes precisely that okay there you go
lansa airplane so black should make Loof
for his King to give his King Air to
breathe so that he can avoid the back
rank
Checkmate black instead of making Loof
makes a terrible decision a suicide
decision
he moves his Rook Charlie Rook E8 check
Rook E8 check that is the best move Rook
E8 check because after Rook E8 check
it's check made in one turn after the
Rooks are
traded check
mate easy I learn yes this is what Bobby
fiser would would teach Bobby fiser also
in his
book this is the best move by far
because it's check made in two moves
there's no question but could white
capture this Pawn as
well Charlie yes yes the answer is yes
we know that Rook E8 is even better
because our goal is to Checkmate the
opponent's king all we need is one
Checkmate per game and we win every
game in this position
white
reasons that he could win a pawn because
after Rook takes it would also be
Checkmate it would also be Checkmate The
Rook would come down and
Checkmate Black's
King okay now let's set the table what's
going on what's going on 1 2 3 4 4 5 6 1
2 3 4 5 6 equal number of Pawns white
has a queen black has a
queen black has two Rooks white has two
Rooks white has a battery on the E file
black has a battery on the D
file both Kings both Kings do not have
lft correct both Kings do not have lft
so in this position it's White's turn to
play How could he Checkmate his opponent
young man in the back yeah well what's
what should white play what's the best
move for white
are
yes
yes that's a very
insightful comment thank you young man
you made a very very insightful comment
what the gentleman was saying was notice
that this queen
and this queen are on the same diagonal
if white could force a trade of Queens
we don't know how he's going to do it if
white could force a trade of Queens
there would be Rook E8 and a back ranked
Checkmate so the young gentleman had a
really clever idea he
thought this Rook is in the way of the
queen trade so let's get rid of Black's
Rook let's attacked Black's rook and as
soon as the black Rook moved
away we could
capture and to show our genius we would
play Rook E8 check and after Rook takes
E8
Charlie oh my
Checkmate so that move C4 was really
good
to attack The
Rook but do you know what Michael Tall a
world champion from the 1960s said he
said if you see a good move stop
think maybe there's a better one let's
go back back back to our position so
this was our starting position and the
young gentleman with his very very
insightful comment suggested the move C4
attacking The Rook with the idea that
when The Rook moves away we'll trade
Queens well what would happen if the
Rook moved
here to
D1 should white capture The
Rook no why
not why shouldn't white capture The Rook
because because the black Rook is going
to capture it and then it will be a
check m
Rook T check che check and then it's not
black who gets back rank
checkm oh no it's white so white could
not capture The Rook correct yeah so
let's say instead White Cap white
captured the queen no but now the
problem from Black's point of view if he
takes the queen he'll lose the Rook but
Black's very clever black says well let
me trade Rooks first Rook takes Rook
takes Rook takes check Rook takes and
now Rook takes
Queen and after C4 we don't get the back
rank Checkmate that we wanted it's like
oh man darn it let's go back back
back okay so
C4 attacking The Rook would only work if
black didn't find his only move after
this move the position's about
balanced so we've got to find a better
move than C4 even though C4 look really
really really attractive Charlie Queen
takes
C5 brilliant
Bingo
Queen takes d
five oh let's go back just for a
second white would love to
play
check but after Rook takes Rook takes
white very confident confidently
announces Checkmate to his opponent it's
not Checkmate because there's a queen
blocking exactly it's but black says no
no no no it's not Checkmate my queen
also defends the E8 Square White's
frustrated and angry he said oh I just
lost a rook well never mind I'll
capture and now what does black
do Charlie que one check oh no white is
a what we say catastroph a catastrophe
has fallen on White's shoulders he's now
the one being back ranked
checkmated oh no fair I want my turn
back now we go back to this position and
white Charley correctly reasoned that
black to defend his back rank Checkmate
he needs both his Queen and his Rook
defending the square White captures The
Rook with his
Queen this comes as a very big surprise
to black black thought that Rook was
wonderfully defended not once but
twice now no matter how the queen is
captured there's a problem what happens
if I capture with my queen Charlie Rook
E8 check Rook E8 check
Rook takes
E8 young man Rook E8 Checkmate Checkmate
so it didn't matter look at this yeah it
didn't matter that white gave up his
Queen for a rook because it was The
Rook that delivered the Checkmate let's
go back back back and let's say wait a
minute let's go back to this
position let's do that one again because
I'm not 100% sure that worked let's take
Queen takes
D5 and let's imagine black this time
doesn't take with his Queen but takes
with his Rook does it make a difference
Charlie it doesn't make a difference
because after
rookie yes the queen Tak that's Force
that's the only move I
agree check again
and all of these checkmating patterns
were shown in Bobby's Fisher's book let
me make it a little bit more
complicated first of all 1 2
3 4 five 6 1 2 3 4 5 6 so the pawns are
even Queen is on the board Queen and
Queen Bishop and
Bishop rook and Rook rook and Rook so
the material balance is even okay in
this position does black have
lft who thinks black has
lft who thinks that black doesn't have
lft oh yeah it has it has lft because it
can move to that square right black has
made lft for his King it's black to move
black to move black is thinking over his
turn and he's putting it all together
for himself so black figures his Rooks
are in a battery and he wants to capture
this Pawn black is a little bit
reluctant to capture the pawn because in
his mind White had just played this move
Queen C3 and black is fearful that this
Pawn will be captured but Black's logic
is impeccable do it impeccable
perfect Black's logic is perfect black
figures that if he captures this Pawn he
will be attacking White's Bishop if
white tries to capture this Pawn he'll
be too late black will take the bishop
and black will have a winning position
young man well why not the queen just
take the Rook
ah you're getting ahead of
Bravo so white black captures The Rook
the pawn with his rook and he thinks he
doesn't have to worry about the back
rank Checkmate because in Black's mind
he has made lft to avoid the back rank
Checkmate that was very clever however
notice what
does does this bishop on E3 protects
what Square young man it protects the H
H7 so that square that is Loof for the
king turns out to be illusion the king
can't move there because this bishop
protects that square so white plays what
Charlie
queen4 correct this is a shock black is
really really really shocked by this
move Queen takes
D4 because black says but can I just
take your
queen no because the go up and Charlie
no because after Rook e Che Queen
Tak e Che because King
H7 is illegal is illegal that
Bishop that Bishop chip
protects the H7 Square let's go back and
let's do another
one another
Checkmate okay so in this position we'll
do another
Checkmate a back rank
Checkmate uh let's
say uh we're going to put a bishop on
the
board and we're going to put another
Bishop on the
board and we're going to put a queen on
the board and a black
Rook okay so far so good we need one
more
situation
here okay let's try to understand what's
going on in this position this is one of
our most complicated position so far
about the back rank Checkmate first of
all let's set the table 1 2 3 4 5 1 2 3
4 five so the pawns are
even white has a bishop black has a
bishop so Bishops are even one two Rooks
one two Rooks so those guys are
even uh one Queen one
Queen
okay yes young man and the kings are all
even and the kings are all even
so what black is kind of expecting is
that more or less the game is even and
that the game will be agreed a draw very
shortly black reckons that white is just
going to trade
Rooks and then after a rook
trade another Rook trade a queen
trade looks pretty even let's say the
queen comes back and it looks like we'll
end up making a draw that is black black
anticipates white just trading off all
the Rooks and everybody makes a draw and
everybody's
happy white sees a move that gives him
the opportunity for a back rank
Checkmate what move does white play
M young man um we can like the bishop
can move the piece to like to um J yeah
that can like block the two squares so
the king can't go anywhere yeah well
after Bishop takes G7 and D that could
be capture I'm not 100%
sure pardon me that it's a good
sacrifice because black could take the
bishop instead white has a different
idea he reasons correctly that this
queen is vital this queen has to protect
this Rook because otherwise The Rook
would make a back rank Checkmate so
white reasons that he must
attack the queen young man do you
know no sorry yes young
man absolutely brilliant Queen to D5 a
few moves ago in a different position
last time we were taking Rooks we
captured a rook and distracted a black
queen this time we don't take anything
we just bring our Queen in the middle of
the board and we just offer our Queen
for free can black capture White's
queen young man no because then it will
unprotect The Rook
correct so that we would end up in our
favorite pattern the back rank Checkmate
y
yay now let's
say
that black cannot capture White's Queen
where could Black's queen go young man
Black's Queen could move to d8 okay
Queen
d8 okay now let's think about what
White's opportunity could
be what move your Rook to E8 check check
and then
and then thees it and
then and the result is white has lost
two Rooks but black has lost his rook
and queen so White's Queen will dominate
Black's Rook like white should get white
should make lft and just make sure that
he doesn't get checkmated even though
the bishop does protect the square white
would have a winning
position let's go
back let's go back for just a
moment and we get this position white
has just played sorry white has just
played the move Queen here we just
discovered that the queen dropping
back wouldn't defend what
if black took the
Rook then what would we do gentleman in
the
back Queen correct Queen captures and
black says
Checkmate
ah it's it's not Checkmate but black
says I want to Checkmate
you exactly where Queen d8
no no oh I forgot sorry the bishop oh
Queen e why not Queen
C8 ah this is your only move but it's
Checkmate okay let's go back back back
so
it's white to
move young man um queen queen
to7 queen to B7 is a good move I like
that move but it doesn't really oh Rook
takes Queen takes oh that's tricky maybe
maybe black will have to move his Rook
off this file so that there's no more uh
back rank check mates remember we
started
here so white put his Queen on pre he
said go ahead and capture my queen I'll
give you a back rank checkmate black
said no I got to maintain the defense of
this Rook I'll move my queen Here
Charlie Queen
E5 Queen E5 now that would be a good
move because you're threatening
Checkmate but what if he took our
Queen oh
dear or the bishop can take yeah but we
just lost a queen for rook and maybe
black would make lft and we would have
no more checkmating threads young man um
instead well you have to go backward of
course so when the queen was there yes I
would move my queen to
A5 Queen to A5 is a very exciting move
cuz you're attacking Black's
Queen but what happened if the bishop oh
no oh no tragedy tragedy is has struck
where else could we move our queen young
man well I was just about this work this
Square doesn't work I'll go in the back
what Square Works
A8 Queen A8 well that's very exciting
you are trying to take my Rook but if he
takes Our
Queen
yeah nothing happened okay so what I'm
looking for is a queen move in this
position a surprising queen move young
man
F7 Queen takes F7 that is a big surprise
indeed because black definitely thought
that that pawn was protected so when he
captures the
queen then then the Rooks can just
form together to get the king I'm not
sure how they can form together to get
the king if you play cck he will just
capture both your Rooks that King that
King has been merciless that defending
King has won a queen and a rook we got
to go back back
back back back
back okay how about this is a
proposition move could white play this
move
Yes actually because even the queen
would would take back the would the
queen would take the queen then the then
you just do the brook trade and white
would win and it would be Checkmate yeah
correct so Queen C4 is a heck of a move
what happens if we go back and after
this move black takes the queen with the
Rook not
with theen correct it would just be The
Rook trade but but there's no Extra
Protection so the queen just to and
Checkmate happens again Checkmate
happens again how cool is that so
Checkmate happens again so isn't this
exciting the
white I told you it was going to be a
complicated
lecture so let's just do this again so
black is in this back rank Checkmate
situation and
white puts his Queen in capture not only
to Black's Queen but also to Black's
rook and in both cases the queen is
immune if you capture White's Queen
you'll be checkmated so black goes
back very
calmly keeps his defense together and
now now white
has to figure out what could white do
now how could White's Queen attacked
this Pawn on G7 young man in the
orange
yeah very
good Queen
G4
ooh what does this move do this move
again it offers your queen for capture
would this be good for black it's
Checkmate the back rank Checkmate Rook
takes E8 as
Checkmate besides threatening to capture
your queen let's say the queen moves
maintaining Rook E8 now what do we do
and gentleman in the
red
correct Queen takes G7 check and mate
because the queen is protected by your
Bishop that's what I said so let's
say in this position black decides he's
very clever black decides to play the
move
F5 the move F5 blocks the queen from
capturing the queen here defends against
Checkmate now what would you guys do
Charlie okay what would you do yes your
to correct correct then queen or itook
and then and then you
like continue to capture okay and
then and then the queen captures it and
the the the checkm
andm checkm Checkmate
ahop is and protecting yeah and and
protecting this square and protecting
the queen so Checkmate so these back
rank checkmating patterns Bobby fiser
spent an entire book teaching his
readers about the back rank Checkmate
and why it's so important and I learned
a lot of these checkmating patterns and
so what I what I say and what Bobby
fiser said better is that be
careful don't fall into a back rank
Checkmate you can make lo and secondly
when your opponents pawns are like this
keep it keep an eye out maybe there's a
backr Checkmate for you
[Music]
[Applause]
n